hey what's going on is philburn it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcasts in
I'm just checking in on you
check in here son my voice is junk I
just did six shows up in San I've been
for the Houston Astros that was all my
favorite players yeah my voice is gonna
be a little tight it's gonna be a little
rough you know I did six shows up there
to Monday to Tuesday to Wednesday just
like when I was in Phoenix to Monday to
Tuesday to [ __ ] Wednesday I'm putting
together my new hour and I really felt
by Wednesday of this week it had gotten
to the point we're starting to starting
to take shape and I was very happy and I
want to thank everybody who came out you
know on school nights I know you guys
all have to work unless you hit the
[ __ ] lottery I assumed all you had to
go to work the next day so I want to
thank everyone in San who came out to go
see me and thank you for sitting through
the new jokes I had a great time up
there worked with Dean Del Rey [ __ ]
crushed it crushed it all [ __ ] week I
had a great time working with them you
know and Dean like this is a funny thing
about Dean when I work with Dean Dean
you know he doesn't party or anything
like that he's done all of that [ __ ] so
he's over it so then you know I'm a
[ __ ] codependent jackass you know
what I mean so I mean to a point
someone's doing coke and heroin I'm like
hey I'm going to bed okay but is when it
comes to the booze or smoking cigars
right that's why you know me and all my
friends I mean we're all codependent
guys we just [ __ ] feed off of each
other and it becomes [ __ ] you know
the animal house but so he doesn't do
that right so miles can be great you
know I'm not gonna spend any extra money
boozing no extra calories I was hitting
the gym was doing everything great but
to think about Dean is he has impeccable
taste and [ __ ] that I like old
instruments old cars he was showing me
this guy that [ __ ] redoes these
Porsche 911s out here that were just
[ __ ] insane insane like he has
like you know not a lot of stuff but he
has all top-of-the-line [ __ ] so I was
joking with the moans like all the money
that I'm gonna [ __ ] not blow in a bar
after my show I'm then gonna spend 10
times more that on [ __ ] eBay after I
get done talking to you but um anyways
he murdered it all week we had such a
great time and San Jose in front that's
one of my favorite places because it's
really it's really it's a small theater
you know from the turn of the last
century at the believed it was built in
the 1890s burned down back when [ __ ]
used to burn down all the time because
it was made out of [ __ ] wood you know
as opposed to what now but well I don't
know we did they didn't have sprinklers
that's what it was what a house is made
out of plastic bill you know you've been
out in Hollywood so long your plastic
phony you think everything's made out of
plastic well then they wouldn't melt
right plastic isn't flammable but I
could just cowers you know what I mean
like your friend who says I got you back
I'm not gonna [ __ ] rat you out then
all of a sudden the teacher comes
walking in egos idea that's what plastic
is you know why cuz it's man-made anyway
so it burned down and then they you know
rebuilt it in the early 1900s and
everyone from like Harry Houdini Charlie
Chaplin they always bring up those two
guys nobody ever says you know Fatty
Arbuckle played here nobody gives a [ __ ]
right I love that name Fatty Arbuckle
you know that's back when you just you
said what the person was for better for
worse you know I mean you know you just
say Fatty Arbuckle why cuz cuz he's a
fat [ __ ] you know sure you had a first
name nobody knows what it is but people
go you know back then it was great you
know you [ __ ] yeah but then o people
also walkin around drop for the [ __ ]
ed work you know like they were saying
pass the sugar but the upside to that
was you knew who thought what as opposed
to now wherever he goes african-american
a homosexual America japanese-american
and you have no idea who's what
everybody's walking around you feel like
you're in the [ __ ] invasion of the
body snatchers who's thinking what right
everybody's reading from the same book
it's not a good goddamn thing I didn't
know what the [ __ ] I'm talking about
right now I literally got off got on the
earliest flight I'm doing this thing now
because I want to run all rush home and
see my daughter my daughter
but I get home because I take the
earliest flight out and I'm [ __ ]
exhausted then I have to go to sleep so
sucks that came home I think she has to
Remember Who I am just three days away
three days away like as far as what
percentage of her life she was looking I
mean like making this face like who the
[ __ ] is this guy she didn't cry thank
God that would have broke my heart but
you know it took me like 20 minutes to
get a smile out of her what else am I
gonna do me a nine-to-five job you know
drive the [ __ ] Chevy Cavalier like
what what the [ __ ] a lot of you guys are
doing right now stuck in traffic I know
you'd want to do that right you got a
dream let me tell you something you got
you're gonna find that train man you're
gotta go after it
okay do whatever the [ __ ] you want to do
you know there's a lot of times I look
at somebody sitting in a cubicle well
that would be great right there I just
[ __ ] sit there I just I go from here
it's a right [ __ ] there
right I just in my chair spins from this
to here right
that's my range of [ __ ] motion I get
my job done and I go home and you know
something that this company goes under I
don't give a [ __ ] okay I'll just go to
another one ain't on me you know that
rent to own rent to leaf that's how you
do it anyways what's going on in my
world other than that I'm excited
finally excited about my new hour
finally finally I've had some [ __ ]
jokes the [ __ ] Boston Bruins dude
they got a win tonight they playing
[ __ ] Tampa Bay Lightning down there
in Florida dude I know like [ __ ]
twelve people already [ __ ] move down
there you know what I mean it's [ __ ]
crazy it's like what are you [ __ ] 80
can't take the winner anymore you got to
lose your edge dude dude I went down
there I visit [ __ ] I visit [ __ ]
whatever [ __ ] Bobby McCarthy do what
he's always walking around in shorts
[ __ ] flip-flops sitting down by a
dock hanging out with all these [ __ ]
weirdos just like dude you know look at
you you've all [ __ ] tanned up
you know it's good but you got to come
back to you got to go to donkeys get to
lodge with extra sugar Bruins in the
middle of a three-game [ __ ] slide we
lost Edmonton and then we went over
Edmonton Alberta and then we went to
Toronto Ontario and we [ __ ] lost
there and then we went to Ottawa the
capital the capital ladies and gentlemen
of Canada
I was actually that's I was trying to
remember all the provinces the provinces
and territories there's ten provinces
and 3 territories up there
I think you'd never [ __ ] remember him
because most of them begin with n
whatever a little enough of them do Nova
Scotia and New Brunswick then there's
something and Labrador Retriever or some
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is that New Brunswick
Nova Scotia Newfoundland and Labrador
Prince Edward Island then the rest easy
you just going across according to
[ __ ] hockey teams to Quebec Nordiques
well Toronto Maple Leafs they're not the
Ontario made beliefs and they're not the
man told Manitoba [ __ ] Jets it's the
Winnipeg Jets right Saskatchewan Alberta
British Columbia then you go up top you
got the northwestern territory
you got UConn and then the other one
like [ __ ] because what an N it sounds
like an Italian word but it isn't like
forget about it the [ __ ] is that thing
called this has to be in the history of
podcasting the most boring thing
anybody's ever brought up Canadian come
on you country a Wikipedia Canadian tear
it or tear it tour territories the [ __ ]
is it called it's something Italian
provinces and territories of Canada
please take out your geography books the
[ __ ] is it called oh yeah yeah no not a
button
oh no that's not doesn't sound tell you
hey we'll have none of it knock it off
no none of that none of that would work
[ __ ] off I got most of them I got most
of them
all right so anyways the Bruins are
playing Tampa Bay tonight we need a win
you know we just [ __ ] beat Edmonton
we just won one of those [ __ ] games
we had little breathing room little
breathing room and now we don't know
it's just like you know Joe bartnick
taught me talked me off the ledge she
goes you know they were [ __ ] tired
they had back-to-back games don't
[ __ ] hit the panic panic button yeah
then we lost again to [ __ ] Ottawa okay
so I'm gonna listen to Joe bartnik cuz
he knows way more about hockey than I'll
ever [ __ ] know but if they lose
tonight we're looking at possibly three
years in a row of being in the playoffs
with two weeks to go in March and then
sitting at home you know which bar
[ __ ] told me that's the worst [ __ ]
thing to just miss the playoffs okay
because you don't get any playoff money
and you don't get a good draft pick but
who knows maybe somebody'll miss
somebody good I mean that's how we got
Tom Brady right everybody just [ __ ]
was looking at him like you know he's
got a nice dimple in his chin but other
than that I don't know you can see why
they passed AB I can see why they passed
him by when he [ __ ] douve after you
threw that pick six you know and the
Super Bowl this year just look that up
him diving to tackle just look and how
unathletic he looks you know any time
anybody ever says like [ __ ] I'd have
[ __ ] at all these teams wait to the
what was he in the fourth round six
round how did they miss this guy just
show that video and just say imagine
that running the 40-yard dash you know
what Tom Brady is he's a [ __ ] sling
that's what he is he showed up looking
like a Volvo station wagon they didn't
realize what was under the hood you know
what it was it was a 454 454 cubic
inches a [ __ ] hat dude sorry
all right plowing ahead other Sports
Talk Formula one starts on this Sunday
if you want to get into it like I did
last year and last year the
mercedes-benz team with Lewis Hamilton
and Nico Rosberg the sense retired Nico
Rosberg because he wanted to hang out
with his daughter which I didn't follow
his kid which I didn't understand until
I came home after three days in San Jose
and my own daughters looking at me like
is this the driver who the hell is this
guy
who knows I always I always want to
blame the woman you know that his wife
was like it's really dangerous
I mean you won the championship I mean
this whole thing with Lewis it's just
it's it's you talk about it all the time
we can't even sit down for a meal I get
it you think he's a [ __ ] but you know I
just what about us can you just be here
with me
you know that's the danger of being with
the wrong woman you you end up stepping
out of a Formula One car and just say
hey you know what
or maybe he's smart maybe he's just like
that guy who plays blackjack and goes up
early and just says hey you know I did
it [ __ ] this I'm going back to the room
taking my money and I'm going back to
the [ __ ] room I have no idea I don't
even understand this goddamn sport to be
honest with you I still don't understand
what happened to the steering wheel and
why it looks like a [ __ ] Gameboy now
and how the [ __ ] sitting there like
driving that goddamn fast you have time
to take your hand off the wheel and
[ __ ] search for that button to pick a
new a new suspension like you're in a
Tesla with your friend driving up
[ __ ] route - hey you want me to put
it in insane [ __ ] mode whatever the
hell it is except they're doing this
[ __ ] at 200 miles an hour by the way I
went by a Tesla dealership when I was up
in San Jose and they have dared the new
one up there you know that had that they
had a you know the original one just had
the motor for the rear wheels now they
got one for the front and the back and
evidently it goes when you get the top
of the line the best one right it's it's
literally with them it's just like what
what gives it makes it worth more money
is the amount of [ __ ] electrical
power you have it's all the bit cuz
everything other than that I think
they're pretty much all the same and if
you get the top of the line one it goes
0 to 60 in 2.5 seconds that's like a
[ __ ] that's motorcycles level speed
and it's a four-door looks like a
[ __ ] Nissan Maxima not even know it
doesn't look like that it looks like
maybe like a Toyota Supra [ __ ] the
Nissan math smack
so my one of those late late 80s ones
was it the Supra the Celica I can't
[ __ ] remember all I know is you know
what car I would love to [ __ ] own for
like a year is one of those like a 71 or
72 like Datsun 510 just have the whole
[ __ ] thing redone I gotta be honest
with you I'm hard pressed to find a
[ __ ] car that I that I can't see that
wouldn't be fun to drive you know I mean
there's so many [ __ ] great cars out
there the only ones I'm not really
interested in is all the American muscle
cars at this point because they're just
[ __ ] everywhere everybody has one
every time you put on mica we got some
Mopar power coming up and it's the same
day it comes a CUDA it comes a [ __ ] a
me this Hemi that here comes the Shelby
here comes the [ __ ] you know that
they only made a couple these Camaros
was the nineteen [ __ ] 69 you know this
is a Mustang boss it's they're all
fighting over the same [ __ ] three
models meanwhile there's all these other
[ __ ] cool ass cars out there I'm
actually glad that the baby boomers are
still infatuated that because it keeps
the prices down of the [ __ ] that I like
yeah I'm a [ __ ] weirdo dude I like
those Ford those Ford vans from the 60s
you know it's just a shame that you know
a couple of [ __ ] serial killers that
dressed up like clowns drove around in
vans they really ruined the name of them
but what the upside of that the upside
of pedophilia is if you're into vans you
can get one for really cheap the
trade-off is you can never grow a
mustache for the rest of your life
that's it anyways the Formula one starts
this Sunday in Australia and last year
the mercedes-benz teams were the was
with mercedes-benz team sorry was the
team to beat and this year evidently the
Ferraris are are looking like they're
gonna be really strong and I guess
everybody's rooting for who the [ __ ] is
the Australian driver therefore the the
Red Bull team he's coming down there
what the [ __ ] his name what's his name
Daniel Ricciardo hello you're getting
ready to leave does she still remember
who I am she was looking at me like who
the hell is this guy alright sweetie
huh I get a smile can't get it she's
staring at the microphone I like that
how are you gonna get in show biz treat
me like a fool yeah I think she's kind
of over me now let me hang with there
for like two three hours yeah today get
the bond back yeah she's just staring at
me she'd rather look at a pillow than me
hey buddy you remember me look at me who
do you think paid for that onesie that
was me nothing she's looking down
he's got no interest unbelievable that's
the kind of charisma huh all right you
guys go have fun I'll see you all right
bye see you later to my two ways all
right so she didn't look at me once I
understand okay it's a brand new brain
still working it she's putting together
her [ __ ] the way I'm putting together my
act either that or she already doesn't
like me but you know I really can't
blame her Daniel Ricciardo is the guy
but here's the thing about him everybody
in Australia claims the guy all right
which is [ __ ] I think because he
didn't move to [ __ ] in Australia till he
was seven he came from Sicily all right
I bet I bet he's got some stories about
everybody teasing him with this [ __ ]
accent when he first showed up to
Australia bet he's got some stories any
Sicilian so you know you know he never
forgets
whatever Australia will let you claim
him maybe you got kicked out like all
those Brits and sent to that [ __ ]
land who knows but um so everybody's
gonna be pulling for him I can't [ __ ]
wait I can't believe how excited I am
for this [ __ ]
that I finally stuck it through one of
those whole seasons now I'm totally into
it so I'm probably born
you but uh who knows alright let's get
to the what's gives us some more
[ __ ] here did Ari talk about
everything oh you know what else think
that when I was up there The Improv up
there found a drum room for me and on
two days I got to play for two hours
both [ __ ] days I snuck four hours in
that's what I do when I'm on the road
cuz I can't really play drums you know
as much as I like which is basically an
hour to two hours every [ __ ] day I
can't do that anymore now I get out you
know a couple couple days a week if I'm
lucky but I got the whole practice pad
kit and all that [ __ ] here so I got to
go out do that [ __ ] see how awful my
playing is now it was really [ __ ]
depressing you know but it was still a
good time all right here we go let's
let's read a little you know what I have
announcements I have to do if I sound
like I'm all over the place it's cuz I
got like two hours [ __ ] sleep flight
was it like 650 a.m. you know and I
never don't do a podcast when I flew the
same [ __ ] day so alright what am I
supposed to do I have to remind the
listeners about Deana Adler Steven
Adler's mom I interviewed her with
Steven Adler and Jamie hadler that was
posted yesterday please listen to it and
Stevens mother mother is gonna be at
Barnes & Noble doing a book signing a
week from yesterday so that will be the
29th March 29th she's gonna be there let
me double check on that make sure I
don't [ __ ] that up that would be a bad
thing
they would defeat the purpose of them
coming on here all right we're at me
where am I yeah the 29th at 7 p.m. at
the growth on Fairfax here in Los
Angeles she's going to be at the at the
[ __ ] if the goddamn mall down there
where they used to have two stadiums by
the way used to have a football stadium
down there and they used to have a
baseball stadium if you ever watched
those
school black-and-white home run derbys
and you wonder where they are I always
thought they were like in like the
Washington Senators the original you
know Washington Senators ballpark but
they were actually out here in LA which
makes sense because it's a [ __ ] TV
show anyways now it's a CBS slot and
where all that [ __ ] stood you know they
knocked it all down and then they did
like 9 million episodes of the prices
right so you know what the world moves
ahead alright Indochina sorry just blew
out your eardrums Indochina everybody
genome talk about how I'm a
made-to-measure suit fits compared to a
generic off-the-rack suit and now every
man looks better in a suit hey why don't
you [ __ ] write something and I'll
read that I got to sit here and riff you
know needs to do that comedian's way
back in the day they probably still do
it we used to go in for commercial
auditions and you'd show up and it yeah
you know there's no copy there's no copy
they just want to see personality and
then you go in there and you hold up the
product and you'd sit there riffing all
this [ __ ] and then they would just steal
all your jokes they wouldn't hire you
and then they'd write the copy oh I
think I told this story
patrisse [ __ ] call them out on it
that's right I think I told this
actually recently to itch I'm staining
that goes you just walked in with like a
can of coke and just stared all like
three of them down just said what what
is this horseshit they all imploded and
told them exactly what the [ __ ] they
were doing all right do I really need
the riff about this okay you know unless
you're unless you're [ __ ] the exact
same measurements of a mannequin you
know you're Nike something's gonna look
[ __ ] up he just not gonna look right
okay if you have a suit that's [ __ ]
tailor-made to your body obviously give
up buy a top for your car you know if
you buy the one for your model your
model car it fits like a glove as
opposed to just getting some generic one
so a little gust of wind and it blows
right off do you want your suit pants to
come flying off and then your dicks
peeking out of your boxers at the
Christmas party or do you want a fitted
suit well thank God for indogene Oh
China whatever the [ __ ] they are they're
making it easy to get a perfectly
tailored suit and an incredible price
you can choose from hundreds of
top-quality fat are there hundreds of
quarks how many are there it's like
cotton silk and rayon in my world the
[ __ ] else is there plastic leather and
it's it I thought there was less fabrics
than there was [ __ ] banks not
individual banks I mean like Chase Wells
Fargo that's what the [ __ ] I mean hey
pail why you just read the copy all
right [ __ ] relax all right
you can choose from hundreds of top
quality fabrics and personalize your
suit just the way you want it whether
it's for work a wedding or another
special occasion whether you're a
defendant you know whether you running
for office
well the accommodated town you're going
to sell all the [ __ ] rubes their
instruments that don't exist
Indochina has a suited up has suited up
hundreds of thousands of men and are now
the largest made-to-measure menswear
brand in the world here's how it works
visit a showroom or shop online in
indochina calm pick your fabric choose
your customizations from lapels to
pleats to jacket linings and more place
your order and wait for it to arrive in
just a few weeks this week my listeners
can get any premium indochina soup for
only 389 bucks
389 boxes of sport coaches I come with
pants and Indochina calm when you enter
burette check out this 50% off the
regular price for a mate to measure
premium suit plus shipping is for free
dude to get a [ __ ] you know a custom
suit you don't made-to-measure for only
389 bucks is pretty [ __ ] good how do
you spell Indochina I am do CH I and O
IND o CH I a know.com promo code bar for
any premium suit for just 3 and $89 and
free [ __ ] shipping all right tell me
what do we have on these [ __ ] Texas
the black tux everybody the black the
black tux what's wrong with the white
one the black tux everybody looking
great for a wedding or special event has
never been easier with the black tux
calm with a high quality rental suits
and tuxedos delivered to your doorstep
the black tux is giving guys a new way
to rent and get this the black tux
offers free home try on so you can see
the fit I always pictured when you're
trying it on some old guys standing on
your front porch looking through this
green door you know his old man clothes
and around his [ __ ] you know with his
tape measure around his neck or whatever
[ __ ] you call it not a tape measure one
thing to tape measure for people
whatever you call it thing the best part
it's completely done online no trips to
the tuck shop required the black D black
tux like The Ohio State the black tux
calm lets you create your look or choose
from tons of styles selected outfits
starting at just 95 dollars these suits
have a modern fit and are made from a
font from fine Italian wool all there's
another fabric cotton silk leather rayon
wool five down 95 to go the highest
quality on the rental market and if you
have any questions or issues their
expert customer care team has your back
every [ __ ] step of the way and after
ordering your suit will arrive 14 days
before your event that's a full two
weeks to try it on and make sure
everything fits if anything is less than
perfect the black tux will send you a
free replacement right away when your
events over just drop your rental back
in the mail shipping is free both ways
how easy is that to get $20 off your
purchase visit the black tux dot-com / /
that's the black tux com / / for $20 off
your purchase alright hey I got to get a
glass of water hold on a second alright
I'm back I'm back I apologize if you can
hear construction in the background it's
not it's not my house thank [ __ ] god
it's the house next door but you know
the houses are all so close together out
here for what
[ __ ] reason probably gives us seven
billion people live out here right
distilled jeans everybody great jeans
they don't have to be complicated no I
can't find the buttons if you're not
into crazy stitching diamonds or
embedded studs you're not alone
distilled pronounce distilled offers
luxury great denim at an affordable
price jeans that would normally cost you
hundreds to still just has four [ __ ]
75 bucks that utilize the same fabrics
factories and watch houses as the best
known brands and designers so the same
[ __ ] poor bastards are washing all
these jeans while skipping the markups
in the middleman the result pure
unadulterated denim without the rental
runaround just go to distilled calm
spelled est LD calm and see where
minimalist design meets maximum comfort
oh these things feel great on your balls
they guarantee the fit they'll ship them
to you for free and you can give free
returns until you find the perfect pair
they actually sent me a pair these
things are [ __ ] great that's great
you don't go them all [ __ ] wonderful
the still has been featured in Forbes
times and TechCrunch as well as on denim
clad celebrities in GQ and vogue
distilled is the only place in the US
you can get this quality of denim for
this price point you can you can find
their amazing selection of outerwear
leather jackets t-shirts and more using
the same principles of the high-grade
materials at low end cost distilled is
your answer to elevate your style just
go to distilled calm / fur right now to
get 10% off your first pair D STL decom
/ / alright LegalZoom mercifully the
last one oh [ __ ] it's national small
business month it always is at
legalzoom.com you know something that
national small business month is like
when you have some [ __ ] store that
always has that sign up that they're
going out of business
going out of business and they're in
business for like another 10 years
anyways national small business month
that legalzoom.com is it's here and
timing couldn't be better
brutal rates for business loans are up
oh great and so is computes consumer
confidence
but it takes a lot more than a good
timing to launch a successful business
that's why LegalZoom created a free
business startup kit part of being an
entrepreneur is utilizing the right
resources to help you succeed you can't
be an expert at everything so go to
legal slash start up today and download
your free startup kit you'll get
educated educational e-books and legal
zone discounts to save money setting up
your business plus you can save
thousands of dollars mucho dinero
through legal zooms partners
what plus you can save thousands of
dollars through legal zooms partner
offers to help with financing marketing
and day-to-day operations things you'll
need to run a successful business did I
write that sentence I could spend 20
minutes trying to break that [ __ ]
thing down front is that a fragment is
that a run-on there's no obligation
neighbor everybody just a lot of great
resources Legal Zoom isn't a law firm
that's not then why would you think that
just because it says legal in their name
but they're dedicated to make life
easier for the business owners whether
you're thinking of starting a business
already run one go to legalzoom.com
slash startup during national small
business month to take advantage of your
free business startup kit that's
legalzoom.com slash stardom oh guess
what I wanted to thank somebody somebody
on Twitter sent me a somebody uploaded
an entire Boston Bruins versus the
Chicago Blackhawks from 1974 and it's
the Bruins feed so it's Fred Cusick
doing the game spoiler alert the Chicago
Blackhawks win the faceoff they win the
draw it goes back to Stan Mikita
who shoots it down to the Bruins end and
it's then picked up by Bobby Orr and
it's that's the whole [ __ ] game I
just set it and it's it's a great great
quality I hope nobody goes in to [ __ ]
takes it down it's unbelievable if you
just want to check it out like the first
thing I always notice asides from no
helmets is like how small the goalies
are
I think than one of these guys scored
like a [ __ ] everybody was scoring 50
goals by so many people scored 50 back
then these guys barely took up like it
looked like a third of the net
stand-up goalies you know they play
goalie they look like they're in the
Rockettes they just [ __ ] kick their
legs out and [ __ ] but it's it's a well
you know actually I'll maybe I'll put a
link to it from the podcast would have
mmm podcasts or at the MMP is that what
the Twitter is I have no [ __ ] idea
anyways that's the that's the podcast
here for this Thursday I got something I
got to go do I apologize I know it's a
little scatterbrained here but however
you can listen to some nice music and
then listen to a podcast from I don't
know when I don't know when it's going
to be it's from from yesteryear when I
was a little bit younger my brain wasn't
a scattered brea it's always been
scatterbrained who's kidding all right
please enjoy the next half of the
podcast and have a nice weekend you
[ __ ]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
this is the Monday morning podcast for
March 25th 2009 [ __ ] podcasters to
start to feel like Groundhog Day for me
I'm going to be a little grumpy a little
extra grumpy this week because I know
what happened I well I do know what
happened I went out drinking last night
and I stayed out until about 2:00 in the
morning and I was driving home and I saw
a coyote and I slowed down and for some
reason felt the need to yell at it you
know just to see what it would do
because according to black comedians
that's what white people do around wild
animals and goddammit I am the
stereotype if that was a black
[ __ ] [ __ ] you keep driving down
the [ __ ] room
why person be pouring over door oh yeah
there Carly what the [ __ ] you doing huh
you want to bite me in the ass that's
literally what the [ __ ] I did I was a
hacky Def Jam bit and those were two of
the worst impressions of two races
you're ever going to hear
but go [ __ ] yourself I'm still in my
pajamas you wear pajamas bill when it's
cold in my apartment I do still
comfortable with my sexuality let me
tell you something if you wear pajamas
as a man and you don't have a child
you're just you're a [ __ ] I don't
know what but you're not something I
want to be around these pajama bottoms
are my way of saying that I hate myself
Oh bill why would you say that anyways
yes oh I just pulled over and I started
yelling at this coyote anyone sounds
like hey hey see if they do something
then I started whistling at him
you know not in like a sexual way I'm
not a creep I was whistling at him like
he was domesticated I just want to see
if I could [ __ ] him up
you know just only come here commitment
give me a boy and thing was looking at
me like do to you serious and I was like
no not really I just want to see what
you would do you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then I drove home and I had some
salami and some horseradish cheddar
cheese and you know what I got the other
day I got this new Sam Adams I really am
a douchebag this week I'm wearing
pajamas I'm drinking Sam Adams if I have
a story that involves me having a
sandwich with an olive in it you guys
should really just unsubscribe to my
podcast at this point or maybe any story
where I'm standing here in a blazer with
a pipe yeah I thought this new Sam Adams
beer like you know they have like their
seasonal ones what is it that is the
BlackBerry something beer I know sounds
gross right that's what I was thinking
like that sounds gross I'm like but it's
Sam Adams somehow they make this [ __ ]
taste good that sherry weak cherry wheat
was something that bears I drank and I
thought it was the most delicious beer I
ever had and by the third one I felt
like I'd eaten a whole bag of candy and
I was like I need to stop but I still
get those I like the Summer Ale so I
figured [ __ ] you know was I just seen
a salmon
is commercial and I [ __ ] challenge you
to not want to go drink 12 beers after
seeing a Sam Adams commercial you ever
see those commercials the guy sticks his
[ __ ] face in those hops grabs two big
handfuls they show how many extra hops
they put in which I don't even know what
that does evidently it makes it more
tasty and then when they put it in that
[ __ ] bad beer glass shape shaped like
a voluptuous woman you know and it just
looks that perfect color that's what was
in my head and I was at the grocery
stores I got man they got a new flavor
and that guy's face in the hops that's
very sexual like he's got it buried his
face and some chicks [ __ ] and then the
end they show her all filled up and
fulfilled you know all filled up and
fulfilled there's a sentence for you
so anyway blackberry sweetie the best
I'm like darker the berry the sweeter
the juice they got me they all went sex
on me and I [ __ ] bought it and I
would tell you that is the worst goddamn
tasting beer I've ever had my [ __ ]
life okay you know I'm a big fan of
these smaller Brewers even though
they're huge Sam Adams is huge now but
I'll tell you Sammy you missed the mark
on that one cuz that tasted like I know
what it tasted like
it tasted like Sam Adams armpit okay
that's it didn't even make sense
understood this avoid the Sam Adams
blackberry whatever the [ __ ] it's called
it's like what the [ __ ] was I thinking
blackberry you know what the
advertisement should that for that [ __ ]
should be it should be it's not a wine
cooler it's not a beer well maybe like
it's a bad cop buddy movie you know he's
a beer he's a wine cooler and together
they taste like ass what is it I'm
actually my refrigerator right now the
BlackBerry Jesus I can't pronounce that
witbier WI t bi er is it some fancy
German way of spelling whatever [ __ ]
word that's supposed to be that's not a
word there's no space between it I mean
what the [ __ ] that is
and yeah I feel like I'm in Woodstock
right now you ever see that thing
weather like stay away from the red tabs
man I'm telling you stay away from the
black berry Sam Adams witbier all right
it's not a good [ __ ] scene it's not a
good [ __ ] scene and yes Jesus Christ
what you know that's it I'm done with
that anytime there's any sort of fruit
in a beer you got to be done although I
do like what is that beer they put the
slice of orange in the I'm just really
going to just say one douche bag think
about my personality after another on
this podcast this is what it is you know
for some reason one of you finds me to
be your hero and you took out the CD
cover and taped it on the ceiling above
your bed you know I just realized I
don't have a poster myself what kind of
what kind of [ __ ] entertainer am i
that I don't have that poster you know
what I mean when I'm standing under the
tree you know both hands up on the tree
branch above me with the little seashell
necklace and my shirt open down to my
neighbor little Sean Cassidy poster
that's when you know you made it that's
when you know you made it when you're
when you're posing for that picture and
nobody around you is telling you it's a
bad idea that's when you know you made
it that's when you know because you are
making so much [ __ ] money people are
afraid to tell you that maybe you
shouldn't be sitting on a tire swing
with one leg in the air you know
for the poster of your upcoming tour
okay that was a long way to go to do a
Sean Cassidy reference um anyways this
is the Monday morning podcast and if you
are new to my page my website or on my
myspace page welcome I do one of these
every single Monday and people send me a
list of questions of questions not
questions questions because it is the
Internet
they send me lists of questions and I
try to answer them to the best of my
ability I [ __ ] pajamas are killing me
I'm [ __ ] up with my brain I don't
know like I lent my brain this week
Flint my [ __ ] brain one of my freak
I'm freaking out about something right
now and I can't even figure out what the
[ __ ] it is but anyways I do this podcast
every single week yeah they send me
questions questions and they send me
their list of underrated overrated
things they give me movie reviews they
ask me for advice they tell me to go
[ __ ] myself every once in a while
someone such a [ __ ] they become douche
bag of the week and lately people have
been sending me stories about revenge
which I find fascinating because that's
one of the few evils that I've I've
actually resisted I have not partake in
Oh before I get too deep into this
podcast well you guys know that my my
stand-up special why do I do this
evidently is on demand so if you want to
have a little party you know get out
your little [ __ ] tea cups in a table
that's way too big for you to be sitting
at because that's what you do at a tea
party don't you does anybody over the
age of fives have a [ __ ] tea party so
they do that over in England
or they just have [ __ ] tea and just
sit there and stare out of the clouds um
all right let's get on with the podcast
okay that was my opening just burst of
energy trying to make this [ __ ] thing
funny because I only got five hours
sleep last night
oh poor [ __ ] baby you only got five
hours sleep and now what he can do a bit
lay around the next day the rest of the
day and you [ __ ] pyjamas you know
what about me and the [ __ ] working
man drinking Boilermakers till 6:00 in
the morning now I'm operating heavy
machinery
go [ __ ] yourself it's not my fault okay
[ __ ] you you're doing heavy machinery
that makes you make them like [ __ ]
thirty bucks an hour thirty bucks an
hour to take down a mountain
all right that made no sense what's so
[ __ ] ever um I just have a bunch of
random notes here notes that I've made
over the past week here's an idea I had
at an airport
nothing suffers like the luggage of fat
people and I don't know how I came up a
bit
I know otherwise I just saw this woman
dragging her wheelie sideways or was it
a guy I can't remember once you get to
that size does it really matter
ever think about that become so big you
just become a sexual this is my late
night DJ boys sort of trying to convince
you with some things all right that was
creepy I'm sorry all right what do you
want talk about creepy let's talk about
how Obama President Obama oh uh
Barack Obama was on The Tonight Show
this week did that disturb anyone as a
[ __ ] American is he and dude where's
my car part two you know what the [ __ ]
you're doing on The Tonight Show I kind
of biggering my girlfriend about that
and I should say uh it's good it's a
great way to reach people it's like when
you have a [ __ ] press conference
right I get to wheel out that podium the
whole world sits around and watches it I
couldn't I couldn't I couldn't sit there
and watch it you know what I mean it's
like Duchin you be like near the red
phone what if the red phone rings and
you're on there you know picking your
[ __ ] March Madness brackets it's
unreal how the presidency has just gone
downhill just over the last [ __ ] 10
years like right around ten years ago
was when Bill Clinton got in peached
because of some [ __ ] skank you know
every president executes can you even
begin to understand not only the amount
of world leaders that have been in the
Oval Office but the amount of [ __ ]
skanks that have been in there that
that's the original Playboy Mansion
all right guys have been in there
getting blown
for centuries women love power guys love
[ __ ] okay and you when you marry the
two you get the [ __ ] Oval Office that
is ground zero for that [ __ ] and the guy
got [ __ ] impeached for it it's right
there I thought that knocked down the
presidency that the president with
[ __ ] Secret Service at his fingertips
can't get a [ __ ] [ __ ] right he
gets busted and and then he had
what's-his-face Georgie part - whose dad
evidently didn't teach him how to give a
speech so we had a look at that [ __ ]
[ __ ] for the last eight years given a
speech where he sounds like somebody
given a book report who didn't read the
book you know what I mean kind of
secondly in Iran he had that [ __ ] and
now we got this [ __ ] going on The
Tonight Show you know like he's Ashton
Kutcher I I don't know I don't like it
this is three three presidents in a row
where I I don't like what they're doing
you wear the blue suit
you wear the [ __ ] tie and you you
should have an air about you that you
and you just shouldn't be able to my
chill you know what I mean and then this
night Joe Paris Hilton Ashton co-chair
it President Obama you know what I
didn't even watch it I'm like really
criticizing I did something I didn't
even watch you know I just couldn't sit
there and watch that showing yeah so did
you and you get dragged the presidential
limo so this is a heavy hand II feel a
heavy hair are you doing don't it we do
it very notes um I don't know all right
let's let's get on with the [ __ ] I'm
really really in an extra [ __ ] [ __ ]
mood right now you know L started last
night when I yelled a dead coyote you
know that's what I did I turn my back on
nature it actually kind of freaked me
out because it was just a couple of
blocks down my down my street you know
what I mean it's like kills sudden is
like a [ __ ] Will Smith movie playing
out at 3:00 in the morning and I was
kind of wondering like wait a [ __ ] that
thing came from I know the Hollywood
Hills are kind of off there in the
distance but uh you know or what a
coyote
Roadrunners huh who watches cartoons I
do but they never catch them one of us
even [ __ ] true you know I mean
Roadrunners can fly right they just
choose not to they'd rather run they
better run be the [ __ ] martyr make
all the other birds feel guilty for
taking the easy way out
alright let's get on with the questions
here because this podcast is in a
cul-de-sac right now I've driven down
the street
it says not a Thruway and I continue
down the [ __ ] Street and now I'm just
driving around in the [ __ ] circle
okay bill um I've been listening to your
podcast since I watched you perform and
because it's nice to hear someone use
the word [ __ ] every five minutes you
know a lot of people have been giving me
[ __ ] about that say I use the word [ __ ]
too much and that they're starting to
use it in everyday life and they're uh
you know they're dropping it in weird
times alright I'm sorry I want to try to
take I'm going to try not to use the
word [ __ ] so much all right
you can't hey he did a [ __ ] joke alright
in addition is a wrestler so the
question bill how do you feel about non
Irish the way non Irish people celebrate
st. Patrick's Day quite frankly it
pisses me off it's a day to celebrate
the patron saint of Ireland not to get
drunk I'm from Cleveland Ohio and here
we have a big parade downtown that's so
annoying seeing the drunks filling the
streets people stereotype us as if we're
the only culture that has a drink once
in a while I'm Irish American and I'm
probably the only woman of Irish descent
who has never been drunk
really
my family and I usually have a
traditional meal of boiled potatoes
carrots cabbage corn beef and Irish soda
bread now let me tell you something if
ever there was a [ __ ] reason to get
drunk it's the kill the taste boiled
potatoes carrots cabbage corned beef and
you can just taste the hot water on the
[ __ ] over boiled vegetables on every
nutrient is just taken out of them you
wonder why as Irish people have such
pasty [ __ ] skin and no pigment if we
boil other than [ __ ] nutrition out of
others out of the vegetables anyways
personally she says I think traditional
Irish food sucks and it's mostly because
they didn't cultivate much except for
potatoes and cabbage well you ever think
maybe they were too [ __ ] drunk to get
a cookbook you know but I do like Irish
soda bread I remember you saying you
don't go out drinking I don't I don't
think I ever said that is that a typo
but you but do you ever do anything and
you like Irish foods um I got a mint I
really do like a corned beef sandwich
and I really do like potatoes I do not
like boiled potatoes boiled potatoes are
disgusting and you need at least half a
stick of butter salt and pepper to just
kill the taste of what you did to it you
know what I mean I'm trying to think of
anything that you should boil other than
drinking water during a [ __ ]
catastrophe you know what do you boil
rice all right then what you boil I
don't know but let me get back to the
question how do I feel about people who
celebrate same taxing I don't go out and
say Patrick's Day that's say it's a very
bad day to go drinking you know
everybody out in their green plastic
hats and that's a green alligator and a
longneck goose yeah it's it's very it's
you know it's like drinking on New
Year's Eve you know and all the dumb
[ __ ] are out with their stupid little
hoary outfits and as if the sound of the
noisemakers weren't ear piercing enough
you got them shrieking over them it's
just a horrible time to go out and I
still administer the question how do I
feel about non Irish people celebrating
st. Patrick's Day I I really could give
a [ __ ] I think it's a statement of I
don't know how empty their lives are or
how the herd just follows whatever the
[ __ ] they were supposed to do you know
it is always like that one traditional
guy and he's got away the skully cap in
the Irish sweater standing over in the
corner cutting into a bar of soap with a
knife you know that guy yeah I could
give em um German Irish and I could give
a [ __ ] about st. Patrick's Day I don't
know the story of the patron saint and
yeah I don't give a [ __ ] I think in the
end when I was in my 20s I used to go
out to pubs on st. Patrick's Day and I
used to do it because I would thought I
could get laid that night because I look
so Irish and then some girl did I oh my
god this is what the day is about here's
a leprechaun right here
maybe I'll blow them that's the only
reason why I went out I was desperately
trying to be interesting but now I just
I don't go out I don't go out on New
Year's and I don't go out on st.
Patrick's Day I don't go out on Flag Day
any sort of Day Earth Day I stay home
but those those are those are just
douchebag days and what you want to do
is whatever people are doing is you you
do it the next day
like Valentine's Day everyone brings
their brought out to go [ __ ] whatever
right you can't get a reservation
anywhere the [ __ ] prices are jacked
up through the roof this is what you do
you go out on the 15th that's what you
do and you tell your woman that that's
what you're doing because you're going
to get a [ __ ] table any way you want
you're not going to get raped on the
charges you probably should be able to
go to a better restaurant then you would
have on the night of the 14th and that's
a great like you know you know a Bronx
Tale to lock the door test that's a
great way to see if you're with the cool
girl or not if she'd let you take her
out on the fun on the fifth
because it really doesn't make a [ __ ]
difference does it you know you're going
to get to see if she is an independent
thinker or if she's [ __ ] stuck in
must-see TV
you know and is going to drag you to the
Maisie day [ __ ] Thanksgiving Parade
one day cuz that's what you do everybody
else is doing you we have to do it honey
it's not that I don't love you we're
just going to get raped here on the
price you know you're trying to find a
bargain on Valentine's Day I want to be
rude [ __ ] but you're in the
relationship - you're not paying for the
[ __ ] meal how does that work exactly
exactly you know what now I'm not even
taking you out well go ahead and cry go
ahead and cry it's not going to work
this is all [ __ ] fake because you
know I just exposed you for being
selfish honey like that now that was
great
you like that you like that little
little riff I did there I always win the
hypothetical arguments okay
well how would how would I go about
getting a personalized autograph DVD set
from you DVD set I didn't know where
they were releasing them in a set do I
have a trilogy of DVDs like The
Godfather how would you go about that
you'd come out to one of my shows that's
what you would do and you'd buy one and
I'd stand there and I'd [ __ ] sign it
for you and I'd smile like a jackass as
I waited the excruciating eight seconds
that it takes for a digital camera to
click before the three flashbulbs
Guilbeau some of those disposable
cameras as bad as they were for the
environment I imagine how great were
those things
say cheese click and it was over now
they [ __ ] got those digital cameras
okay one two three and then you sit in
there waiting and waiting with that
[ __ ] smile plastered on your face you
know like that [ __ ] newscaster goes
to throw it to the other newscaster in
the field and then it doesn't go and
then you're just staring at the entire
state that you're broadcasting to now
off to Mike out in Chelmsford
okay we seem to be having some technical
difficulty that's what it's like getting
your picture taken on a [ __ ] digital
camera any what's even better is when
they accidentally hit video and then
you're standing me with a smile on your
face like you start talking through your
teeth oh my god
hold the button down you got to hold it
down you know many times that's happened
to me after my shows and I'm like oh my
god I had it on video and those are the
times when I wish I didn't sell [ __ ] at
the end of my shows you know I like
meeting people after my shows I
definitely like doing that but you know
sometimes you feel like a [ __ ] idiot
you know special people come up to you
and like you know dude do this joke
can you just say pesto and then we'll
take the picture no no I can't oh my god
you're so grumpy shut up
take the picture um alright anyways he
said anyway let me go on with this guy
says I'm happy to pay for it and I have
a downloaded copies paid for to my
iPhone but I want an autograph one so
let me know what I need to do to get one
where how to pay for it alright I'm kind
of being a douche err but like you know
people ask me for like autographed
photos and [ __ ] like I'm Fonzie
sometimes and they never they like
expect me to pay the postage and all
that type of [ __ ] and it's just I'm not
doing that okay alright I hang out at
the end of my shows I take pictures I
oughta graduating but kiss [ __ ]
babies alright I do this podcast every
week I'm not going to get myself into
the situation where I got to go to the
post office you know every [ __ ] you
know every other day alright with manila
envelopes I'm not doing that [ __ ] you
know trying to think of something to
write before assignment that's the
hardest thing about giving an autograph
can you make it out to Susie and then I
always write Susie and then I sign my
name and I'm like then I try to think
what to write I'm like
god bless a Suzie what's going on bill
burr ah [ __ ] all right
who complains about signing autographs
you know what I do I do
okay okay let's go let's get on with
some really sound like a [ __ ] where
do I get off complainin I like I acted
like I would see someone asked me for a
photograph every other day I was going
to say every 20 minutes and I'm like
they'll never believe that I'll say
every other day that's not even true
it's usually like once a month and it's
usually somebody with a fatal disease
and I still don't send it to them
because that's the kind of guy I am
alright also bill let me move on here
you should really promote the broadcast
okay bill you should also you should
really promote the podcast for download
on iTunes the [ __ ] is so easy that once
you do it you have the podcasts on your
iPhone you can listen to it in the car
anywhere other than in front of a
computer well there you go everybody
you can download it on iTunes thank you
sir you just hyped it for me
all right last week I had a big question
about the difference between hotels and
motels and first of all before I get
into this [ __ ] how about those Bruins
huh beat the New Jersey Devils I got any
new jersey devil fans out there do you
like that little four to one victory I'm
just [ __ ] with you you guys got a
great team and if you're not watching
hockey right now I really feel bad for
you all you guys watching March Madness
and you know waiting for that that awful
song at the end of the tournament when
they show the great moments I had a
dream usually picked like Melissa syrupy
song as they show all the dunks and
slow-motion and the people being excited
and then crying what is this song that
they think tonight I need your sweet
caress hold me in
darkness tone you right now playoff
hockey's coming the Flyers are playing
great
the Rangers lost yesterday but they're
coming on the capitals of [ __ ]
ridiculous the goddamn Devils got a
insane team as always I really hate I
really hate the Devils I just hate their
I hate the country style of hockey that
they played throughout the 90s with the
left wing lock in the trap defense I
swear to God not disrespecting you know
Marty Broder over there and the big
record that he got but you know it's a
little padded it's a little [ __ ]
padded with the [ __ ] trap defense I
mean he spent half his career have to
save he made was skating behind his neck
stopping the puck because they just
would dump it in because they clog up
the neutral zone and you know what I
mean and I was also during the clutch
and grab era Jesus Christ I could have I
could have squeezed out a couple of
shutouts
alright that's [ __ ] I just I just
hated that period of hockey and when I
think about that period of hockey I
think about the New Jersey Devils and I
don't still to this day I don't
understand why the NHL just didn't say
that's an illegal defense you know what
I mean it's like when Wilt Chamberlain
was [ __ ] Duncan on everybody you know
they came up with rules to keep it
competitive because it's a [ __ ]
business
you know the three-second rule you can't
have some guy just standing in the
[ __ ] paint who's nine feet tall
goaltending they came up with that [ __ ]
and they came up with the legal defenses
I still don't know why they allow that
defense it's the worst [ __ ] they to get
rid of the red line because of that [ __ ]
I know but I was watching yesterday and
they don't play it anymore so I really
enjoyed it but as usual they just got
great [ __ ] players and they play
smart [ __ ] hockey and I don't know I
don't know it's going to be a tough
[ __ ] road and for those of you who
don't know this is a question I ask you
who the [ __ ] are these people who are
trying to get the fighting out of hockey
I don't understand them you know watch a
different sport
hockey's not for you all right
and if it's somebody in hockey stop
doing it don't get rid of fighting in
hockey all right and think that you're
going to be as popular as baseball
basketball or football you're not all
right you're a rogue [ __ ] sport
you're really hard about hockey's if you
never grew if you didn't grow up playing
it or in like a hockey family or in a
hockey town it's one of the hardest
[ __ ] game to watch on TV I was kind
of noticing that yesterday like you
literally have to be not only watching
what's on the screen but what is like
literally 20 feet to the left of your
screen you know what I mean you got to
you got to figure out like guess when
they're like you can after a while you
watch it long enough you know what's
going on to the left or to the right of
the play that is literally off the TV
screen you just got the change in lines
like you just know [ __ ] like I can't see
the puck well [ __ ] watch bowling you
blind bastard all right here's a
question I had last week someone I asked
what's the difference being a hotel in a
motel you know I mean and I thought it
was basically yeah you know if your door
opens up out to the parking lot that is
a [ __ ] motel it's a serial killer
doesn't have to kill somebody at a front
desk and get in an elevator or at least
walk a hundred yards of carpet before he
kills you that is a hotel no that is a
motel I'm sorry if he has to do that
[ __ ] that is a hotel and evidently I am
right because one person said that I was
and that's the amount of research that I
do with everything in my life bill if
you drive up to your room you're at a
motel and you deserve to hear the people
[ __ ] next to you oh wait I read that
wrong because I have dyslexia let me
start over again take a deep breath
focus you can do this bill if you drive
up to your room you're at a motel and
you deserve to hear the [ __ ] people
next to you talk about their free
[ __ ] HBO okay that was really funny
and I butchered it anyway he goes uh
that [ __ ] sucks also you're killing me
you [ __ ] killing me you spent $89 on
a cheap motel are you [ __ ] nuts
I always hear about this internet stuff
but I never do it and he writes in
capital letters food then he goes back
to regular typing listen to me go to
Priceline next time you're traveling and
look up a hotel and pick the highest
star rating and do not bid any more than
89 bucks and you'll get the best hotel
in the city for that price I would tell
you to go down to 59 or 69 bucks but
just stick with 89 bucks please just try
it once I travel the road for 14 years
and I kick myself in the ass when I
realized what I've been missing out on
thanks for the free podcast - the
highlight of my Monday mornings well
thanks for the [ __ ] info
I said William Shatner's [ __ ] I never
even
I don't even pay attention to
commercials I just look at the [ __ ]
the glitzy lights I'm like I love a will
[ __ ] blames Shatner you know he's
keeping it going guy did Star Trek 40
[ __ ] years ago and he's still working
you know and he has a hell of a
toothpick alright Ashville here we go
is the advil section of the podcast that
I just stuttered there I was alright as
bill bill I need your advice I had
something very horrible happen to me and
oh man this is brutal settle into your
[ __ ] your staples office chair for
this one people this is this is a tough
situation all right I don't know if I
got the life experience to get you out
of this one ass bill okay bill I need
your advice I had something very very
horrible happen to me
and it's nobody's fault but mine
nobody's fault but mine been an and and
NSR Led Zeppelin alright have this I
have this friend who don't get me wrong
is a good friend but is that one type of
friend who's really [ __ ] annoying but
wanting to hang out 24/7 just recently I
got a new girlfriend and I've been
spending all my time with her my friend
then became jealous becoming more and
more annoying by making me feel bad for
being with my girl anyway long story
short to vent I wrote an E
l to my girl just trash in my front I
put down the [ __ ] road for being the
[ __ ] wait a minute could you use a
smaller type set you know I suck at
reading bulk I see trashing my friend up
and down but being the [ __ ] that I am
and here we go people instead of just
sending it emailing it to her I check to
send all option sending this horrendous
email to everyone on my email list oops
my email list doesn't really have too
many people on it but it does have the
friend I was trashing of course it just
me it just made me realize that you
shouldn't say things behind someone's
back if you can't say it to their face
so I'm nominating myself for douchebag
of the week lol what would be your
advice send an apology email or just
ignore them
ah that's the worst that's the worst
because you know what sucks about that
is you you're a hundred percent in the
right that this guy is a douchebag but
now you became the douchebag because any
what's funny is if he had a girlfriend
he would be doing the same thing he just
wouldn't have been dumb enough to
[ __ ] send hit send to everyone uh I
don't know what should you do should you
send an apology email no first of all
stop writing things down on paper that's
number one don't ever do that and number
two learn how to spell apology there's
no e I wouldn't just ignore them you got
to take it like a man you just gotta
walk up to him just do it yeah you know
I wrote it and you know what I meant it
you've been a [ __ ] and that's it so you
want to punch me in the face knowing
that I'm going to defend myself and
punch you too so you know that's kind of
where we're at I know it sucks
I don't know you know what I think
I'm getting uncomfortable thinking about
the situation you put yourself in I
really don't know what to tell you I
don't know what to do with that one you
got caught and you [ __ ] you kind of
turned yourself in you should be on
America's dumbest [ __ ] talkers you know
you know that show write America's
dumbest criminals and the guys put
whipped cream on their face and they
stand in line at the bank and it melts
off their face by the time they get up
this with this guy you did the email
equivalent of that I don't know what you
got to do I mean I would just I feel
laughs I have no you know what I got no
advice on this one I got I got it I got
to throw this to the listeners all right
I got to go to way yeah what do they say
that you got a I got a phone a friend
here if anybody has any advices what
what the [ __ ] this guy's supposed to do
I'll read it next week because I don't
know what to do you've you've it's
checkmate checkmate I don't know what to
do dump your girlfriend change your name
and move to Alaska either that a you
just I think you just got to take it I
think he just got to take it all right
so what did you learn
no more [ __ ] emails right and you got
to watch out - because you vent - you
[ __ ] girlfriend's and even even when
she's in a good mood she's still going
to tell half the [ __ ] story - to one
of her close friends you know I mean I
don't know why they just say really I
don't know you think women know bad at
keeping Indian guys are overrated but
their ability to keep a secret I'm going
to keep it a secret because I forget
[ __ ] not because I have any sort of code
I just you know I have really bad memory
and after like three days I can't
remember like you could literally be
like Bill you know what don't say
anything but I [ __ ] so-and-so's wife I
feel like [ __ ] I can't believe it I have
so much guilt I just had to tell
somebody please don't tell anybody and
I'd be like yeah okay yeah dude the
problem the problem and literally I'm
not saying - three days later but if by
a year and a half if I went out to
dinner with all the people involved
maybe sometime around dessert I would be
like Oh
a minute wait a minute he [ __ ] up guys
why is right that's right so I thought I
can keep a secret I just I can't [ __ ]
remember yet though we got it we got it
then we understood with the example you
don't need to go back into it why don't
you wrap up the [ __ ] podcast alright
you're 40 [ __ ] minutes in alright
relax it'll be a long podcast I don't
get going here uh alright let's get on
to revenge stories okay this is a
question I have because every revenge
story seems to be from guys none of them
seemed to be from females so finally a
woman chimed in with some sort of
revenge but it wasn't really revenge or
maybe it was revenge and she was just
doing a typical thing that women do when
they tell stories is they never get to
the [ __ ] point no kidding
oh Jesus I'm crabby Taylor all right
here is one from a home on bill I
usually don't take serious revenge on
someone but I do take I take so much
pleasure in other person's fuck-ups and
misery I always take comfort finding out
that someone I hate has such a miserable
life here's a story about my egghead
douche ex-boyfriend all right I already
like the sound of this alright to start
to start the story I will admit that I
was a [ __ ] who rarely gave him any
sexual anything sexual for two years
Jesus Christ that's one of those
relationships that died the final two
years and no one no one just had the
nerve to be like hey so why don't we
both just [ __ ] off anyways she goes at
least he put up with with that [ __ ] any
other guy would probably want to do
starve or get sick of it and dump my ass
anyway he always played a PC games such
as World of Warcraft
he got so [ __ ] engrossed in that game
and paying money every month to renew
his subscription what a dumbass however
players can talk to other players in
their guild or on their side of the game
after I broke up with him I found out
that he was talking to some chick behind
my back for a year the story gets better
this is uh this is where my revenge
happens I don't have to do [ __ ] to ruin
his well I didn't have to do [ __ ] to
ruin his life okay so after I dumped his
ass he continues talking to the [ __ ] he
meant for them from the game he thinks
he's in love with her
parentheses [ __ ] so he goes to Canada
to be with her where she lives
I guess he thought she was going to be
the one and he proposed but a month
later he gets deported back to America
and like a dumbass he lets her keep the
$3,000 ring on her finger after a short
period of time he tried to go back but
he gets deported again so he's a college
dropout who lives at home with his mommy
and he's out three grand in addition
while after he starts dating on addition
a while after he starts dating this
Jewish [ __ ] they were dating for about
a year and a half one and a half years
then she dumps him because she decides
it doesn't it's not going to work out
because he's Catholic and the icing on
the cake is that all I have to do to
make him feel even more pathetic is let
him find out I bang my boyfriend and
everything he does usually comes back to
me because he keeps in contact with one
of my good friends anyway anyone who was
on my bad side who has [ __ ] with me
has always had something come back to
bite them in the ass I take great
pleasure in that Jesus Christ wow that
is a [ __ ] yeah hell hath no fury I
love how you dumped him and you think
he's a loser and you're still getting
enjoyment that he has this horrific life
that's scary man you know I usually
expect that sort of evilness out of guys
you know that's just really frightening
like that's that's a mom that's gonna be
somebody's mom no mo are wire hangers ah
all right bill there's another of story
of revenge you know what there was what
that story could think I'm being a jerk
to that person it's that the guy really
didn't do anything to you you know he
was a lame dude
he was a loser you dumped him and then
his life continued to go down the toilet
and I know and you just enjoying him
getting dizzy as he goes down and I
don't [ __ ] get anyways
anyway savoury here we go French Story
number two about 20 years ago I was
living in downtown Chicago by the way
this person is telling I know I read
really bad out loud but this guy is
typing even even a smaller type I don't
understand can you guys type a little
bit bigger and don't be a [ __ ] and just
give me the biggest size okay that's
really a second-grade joke all right
we're trying to do something serious
here people do whatever you want I don't
give a [ __ ] I'll sit here and start it
through the emails bill okay let me get
out my magnifying glass about 20 years
ago I was living in downtown Chicago and
a high-rise that had a multi-level
parking garage I paid a monthly fee and
had a designated coverage spot this guy
was doing great it sounded like you
worked like one of those [ __ ] 20 years
ago I think he was selling health
insurance anyways one night I came home
to find another car parked in my
assigned spot and since it was about
2:00 a.m. I just said [ __ ] it you know
and drove to the roof deck where there
was always plenty of open spaces at
about 10 a.m. I was looking out the
window of my apartment and I saw a tow
truck driving down LaSalle Street with
my car attached to the back since I was
on the 18th floor there was no chance to
catch the tow truck so I went down to
the office and asked the manager
management why my car was towed she said
that I was parked in someone else's spot
I explained that someone was parked in
my spot and that there was probably 30
empty spots on the roof deck plus the
fact that my car had a sticker on the
windshield showed that I was a resident
she said that there was nothing she
could do and I ant so I asked to speak
to the person who had my car towed she
called the girl who had my car towed and
she came down to the office she was a
total [ __ ] about the whole situation and
insisted that she did the right thing
well since I couldn't blast this [ __ ] in
the face I decided to take revenge on
her car since I knew exactly where she
parked once again
revenge is coming back - [ __ ] up
somebody's car alright so here we go
here is the revenge I waited about two
months and then I got a syringe from my
mother who was a diabetic did you make
sure she had an extra one I hope you
didn't take her last one see see what
happens when you go down the road of
revenge next thing you know you stealing
more syringes from your mom
so anyways I still syringe from my mom
who's a diabetic then I went to a
sporting goods store and bought Rutte
which is basically deer urine I then
proceeded to load the syringe with rut
and I injected in it I injected it into
all the rubber moldings around the
windows of this girl's cars it smelled
awful my parking spot was one level
below her spot and I could smell it
every day I know that taking revenge on
a car is a Wimpy move but it did feel
good always remember revenge is a dish
best served cold Jesus Christ
wow man do you went like [ __ ] CIA on
that that's like something they would
miss him like the autopsy because it's
little [ __ ] needle [ __ ] holes I
got to admit that that is definitely I
mean [ __ ] up somebody's car is not to
original but that is that dude you grew
up in the backwoods no city kid knows
about rut you know what I mean yeah you
grew up in the backwoods you did didn't
you
your mom's a diabetic you know lived in
a trailer ate off a George Foreman grill
you're going to show everybody in your
high school class that you were better
than this she got some big fancy job you
lived in a high-rise you had your own
spot you know and you were looking out
your window looking out over the South
Street stroking your [ __ ] and you
thought you had the whole world by the
balls and what happened they told you
[ __ ] Mazda Miata right out of your
goddamn spot right and it brought you
right back to your chat
didn't it and then you took revenge the
same way those kids took revenge on you
in second grade I don't want to [ __ ]
go with this [ __ ] alright let's let's go
to this next one
alright bill just another story of
revenge bill so I did it check for two
years on and off and this was my first
real girlfriend in high school and I
thought she was the perfect most amazing
girl in the world I was an idiot and
like 17 years old I'm still an idiot 23
but I sure as hell won't let this crap
happen again
anyways I let her walk all over me and I
just took it like a [ __ ] it was the
kind of thing where she could [ __ ]
cheat on me in front of me and I
believed her if she told me she wasn't
I was I was that [ __ ] pathetic
eventually though after hearing that
your girlfriend is cheating on you for
so long it eats away at ya oh can you
hear the foreboding music in the
background eventually she posted some
[ __ ] poem on MySpace on myspace
about some dude she was going out with
at the same time she was going out with
me wow that's pretty bold and anyway she
goes the [ __ ] uh who she was cheating
with even had the balls to post on there
talking about how sweet she was so
finally I had my proof she wasn't
getting out of this and here comes the
revenge
so I actually messaged the guy and
started telling him that I've been
[ __ ] her the whole time that he's
been going out with her he starts
telling me that he he even knows of her
cheating on him and he took her back so
we teamed up to destroy her see see this
is this is this is where it goes wrong
this is where it gets evil so I do not
partake they're teaming up now to
destroy another hipot thing and this is
how it plays out alright here we go
by this time I was out of high school
and they were both and wait a minute by
this time I was out of high school and
they were both at the same high school I
guess the guy in this girl basically I
showed up to her school and what we did
was bring up all this [ __ ] that she did
up in the middle of all her little
[ __ ] friends she cared about so much
she cared so much about and explained
how much of a horse she was other dudes
even came out
and said they were going out with her at
the same time I was [ __ ] her and [ __ ]
this [ __ ] was the [ __ ] public
bicycle everyone was riding will it
completely ruined the rest of high
school for now five or six years later
me and the dude are still friends
there's a win for there's a win for the
guys who got treated like [ __ ] out there
yeah it is
yeah I guess it had a oh that's just
[ __ ] I don't know man I cut my losses
I cut my losses that reminds me of an
intervention story where there was this
girl whose dad didn't stick around so
she I don't know what and she develops
young and uh the guys be like hey let me
see you titties and she just shown him
to him not realize she just liked the
[ __ ] male attention
so she's dancing as a cheerleader and I
don't know what she did she blew a
couple of guys and so she's dancing as a
cheerleader in the hope her her entire
college I mean high school class just
started chanting or [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] or
something like that and then she bursted
in tears and she became a [ __ ]
alcoholic you know I'm saying but you
know something you don't you don't have
the mentality to know that at that age
and I show wasn't on so why am I playing
armchair quarterback and ruining your
revenge I don't know revenge enema I
don't know [ __ ] creepy men we've
ruined the rest of high school for and
then we high-fived and kicked a puppy
alright here we go
overrated underrated this is the last
thing here overrated and this is
something that I've been meaning to
bring up this is one of the I overrated
that I agree with I think the most
overrated multi-blade razors a few
months ago I started using my dad's old
double aged
made almost 20 years ago before I was
born born it's [ __ ] great my face
feels better than ever and I can get a
hundred blades for less than what it
costs for an eight pack of those three
or five blade cartridges if you get a
shave like a man and introduce an
element of danger to it I actually have
a couple of straight razors too but it's
too much work and I don't use them on a
regular basis there's nothin to it those
[ __ ]
one of the worst things ever happened me
on the road was I left my toiletries
behind I think in Tampa a long time ago
not only did I use lose my little tough
crowd
shaving kit bag I lost that [ __ ]
thing and I lost my twin twin blade
razor and then I went on to the triple
rape blazer and I have a whisker
underneath my nose that it just can't
get it just doesn't get it
it sucks around your chin it is terrible
the two blade razor is the [ __ ] and you
will never get a closer shape than that
everything else is [ __ ] [ __ ] I
was wondering know what about the even
seeing those things on TV we can sharpen
your razor blades anybody I mean anybody
buy one alone stuff this podcast going
on well my god 53 months minutes I got
to get out of here all right
underrated your podcast it's [ __ ]
great thank you very much I appreciate
that here's another good one overrated
chicks and bars and clubs underrated
chicks at the laundromat the skill set
in these two groups is so far off it's
ridiculous chicks and bars and clubs
just spackle on so much makeup that they
can barely hold their heads up long
enough to accept your drink before they
shoot you down but dude dramatic pause
raising my eyebrows type [ __ ] you
actually type that helping me with my
reading ability I like that I like
direction but dude a chick in the
laundromat is so sexy it's crazy they're
wearing probably the last clean [ __ ]
that they own that's just a little too
tight they don't MIT they don't put on
makeup so dude you're really sounding
like a pervert right now you know they
were in that last few to clean closet
they got yeah that's a little bit too
tight
damn put any makeup on it they're pretty
at that moment and they look
unbelievable and you know they all look
like that for the rest of time just
reading the rest of your [ __ ] like a
pervert actually dude you're actually
you're right you make some great points
here plus they're doing some
responsabilité
while they're hungover and then try not
to throw up on their newly clean clothes
sorry I went too long yeah dude you did
you're actually making a great point you
do yeah you did
alright that's the end of the podcast
okay it kind of petered out kind of like
the Colorado River not reaching the
ocean anymore
um anyways before I'm going to be in st.
Louis this week at the house of comedy I
have the link right there on my website
go to Bill burr comm bu are are calm and
I want to thank everybody who came out
to my Monday shows at the punch line in
San Francisco I really wish I talked
about that in the beginning be honest
with you those were two of the best
shows I've ever had in my life that
second show it was ridiculous for those
of you who weren't there I just started
telling stories and I probably did close
to an hour and a half 15 minutes of
which was actually from my AK so uh you
know it was all material I'm never going
to do again because it was all family
stories and [ __ ] up [ __ ] that I would
never talk about on TV so I hope you
guys enjoyed it I had a great time and
I'm thinking about coming up there again
in a couple of months had the punchline
and maybe haven't that be a regular
thing just coming up on Mondays and
doing a couple of shows and just venting
about the people in my life you know and
not having to worry about them ever
hearing about it alright and that is it
thank you for listening to the podcast
thank you guys for contributing and uh
what else
oh I you know what I people have been
asking me about my myspace page asking
about the comments I kind of haven't
been adding accepting comments since the
last September I just kind of forgot
about it I just was adding friends and
answering emails are you the podcast
took up a lot of time so I'm back to
accepting comments I literally had like
400 or 600 comments that didn't allow me
to hear his comment approvals I'll click
on this right now this is this is
garbage time right now you're going to
listen to this [ __ ] I have 419 that I
have to approve so I'm trying to try to
get back on that [ __ ] but anyways that's
it thank you guys for listening to the
podcast and I'm going to try to get some
new photos up there on my website
and on the MySpace page that's it you
guys have a great week okay bye-bye